what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel
um today I am going to be continuing my
divorce documentary where I sit down
with uh men that have dealt with the
family court system in the UK um
sometimes this is divorce sometimes it
is
um you know an ex-girlfriend someone
they had children with today
um I have Brian Dawson yep welcome
welcome to the show thank you very much
thank you for having me
um so you messaged me on Twitter uh and
you said that you had a story to tell
yes yes so
um I know I just asked this but so you
have um two daughters two daughters yes
um and how long has it been since you've
seen them
um it's been over a year since I've seen
my 15 year old and it's been
three and a half four months since I've
seen my 13 year old okay
she said 15 and 13.
um okay so I want to start with like
where did you meet was it an ex-wife or
ex-girlfriend ex-wife ex-wife okay yes
uh we met in please go back up on
Twitter in the north of England okay
um she she was adopted when she was very
young and brought to England from
Australia by your parents
and went to school down south and I
moved up north and she had children from
a previous relationship and she was
moving around the country with her
ex-husband who was working for Holiday
parts or something like that and I met
her after they separated and she was
living on her own in the north of
England I met her on a website funnily
enough yeah I met him on a date inside
and uh things kind of went from there so
you're a stepdad too I was a step dog
too yes how many kids were your stepdad
to four wow so she had four kids okay
okay how old was she out of curiosity
and she's two years older than me I'm 47
at the minister she's 49 would have been
maybe about
29 shoes but I met her I would have been
about 27. okay yeah I've just noticed a
trend where the girls are between the
ages 25 and like 32. right so yes it was
just a trend I've noticed um okay so
what
so when did you guys get divorced we got
divorced in 20
19 okay we split
um 2018 January 1st
and then you have to wait again before
you can divorce or you get to that data
providing up with the divorce papers and
then did you file or did she
um maybe I filed for divorce yeah okay
you filed
um okay so when when did the custody
battle start
um it started in Australia
um because she's Australian yeah and we
moved over there in 2015
um and we lived there up until 2020
and it was uh 2018 when we split
and 2019 we got a divorce in 2020 we
went through the courts for custody of
the youngest children the biological
children with me okay so it was the the
whole custody battle in Australia then
no okay okay
um I won custody in Australia she was
stripped of All rights no way yeah she
had no obviously children at all she was
stripped of any kind of preventive
responsibility wow yeah and that's hard
to do there I've heard too it is yes I
was in the Detention Center I wasn't
even on Australian soil so legally you
can't give me custody because I don't
have
um I don't have
any kind of place to release the
children too that couldn't be put in my
care because I didn't have anywhere to
live well I wasn't allowed in the
country so it's very rare that that
would ever happen as well but because
the circumstances leading up to that I
was granted full provincial
responsibility and the children returned
to the UK with myself okay so 2018 you
filed for divorce 2019 filed for divorce
oh sorry 2018 the relationship ended
2019 you filed that's correct
um why did you file what was the did you
guys have Iraq and Sir like what was the
official reason
um
she was a very hard person to live with
she was uh very angry all the time
and the bunch of it went to the children
and she came in hungry one day and it
was um she's 15 now but at the pain she
would have been 10 I think or 11 and she
was scared and she says I wanted to take
me out of here I don't feel safe here
anymore I don't want to live here
anymore and I was like
I'm thinking myself I'm only here for
you kids anyway so yeah let's go let's
just leave
um I think she kind of knew something
was coming because she was taking the
children away individually to talk to
them and tell them what a bad man I am
and how she's a biological mother and
and this that the other
um and while she was taking her eldest
out
having to talk to her and the younger
two went packed the bags and I packed a
bag for myself and when she came back it
was the the children that said look we
need to have a talk but I mean don't
feel safe here anymore I want to leave I
want to go away with Daddy and that's
when we left she phoned the police and
says I was attacking her
wow so the kids said they wanted you to
leave yes because they didn't feel safe
we didn't feel safer and so 2018 that
was when the relationship ended and 2019
you filed that's correct and then when
did you get custody 2020 2020 yes okay
so 2020 you got custody and you left the
country with the kids that's right yes
okay and she's still in custody to the
four previous kids uh yes but they were
older so oh they were out of the house
okay and does she have like a
relationship with them the older kids
she does
um
she's got a son who lives in England
uh she's got two daughters that live in
Australia within they live in the same
house and her eldest left and came with
came with us when we when we split up so
she lives over here in England oh wow
okay
so
um when when did the custody battle
start in England then in England it
started in March the very end of March
last year
okay so we're in 2023 so 2022 yeah yeah
okay so March 2022 what happened yes
um
uh my 15 year old at the moment
uh had a big kick off because I wouldn't
let away make up and uh short skirts for
school okay so she had a big meltdown
and a big kickoff and went at the school
and and cried about it
and the teacher said oh you've been
abused
that's what the teacher said kind of let
you go back home so the teacher said
that she was abused because she wasn't
allowed to wear makeup yes
wow okay yes they said it's child abuse
and they kind of let her come home
so the phone Children's Services
so the school phone school phone
Children's Services yeah
and this is in their report that's
exactly what it says yes
yes okay
Children's Services okay
and Children Services in the school
contacted the mother
and then that's when everything just
started blown up okay so
and Children Services is that I get a
bit confused by all of the different
organizations they they basically are
just supposed to make sure the child's
safe yes okay
and not being abused but they're saying
that makeup is abuse and are they part
of family court system you know like
what organization they're under uh it
just all falls under the umbrella term
local Authority oh so this is under the
police it's kind of like okay they're
just labeled as local Authority in the
paperwork they're always called LA but
Elliot said this that Elliot provided
this not the other okay so the school
phoned okay over makeup now your wife
has custody of the daughter
uh are your wife like she the like where
does where does your daughter go home
that night
oh okay so
she was in foster care before they even
spoke to me
how was she in foster care
because when she cried out the school
not being allowed to wear makeup and not
being allowed to wear short skirts is
I think their words are massively
concerning and she was under threat and
she no circumstances would she allowed
to come back to the home so they
arranged a faster placement over here
and and notified me later on that
evening that she was on her way to a
foster placement
so you just took your kid wow
okay so what happens next obvious
obviously you're pissed oh um beside
myself this is my eldest daughter a
biological eldest biological daughter I
was devastated
um I understand kids have tantrums and
they kick off and you know I might have
been guilty of spoiling them a little
bit since yeah you know coming back to
the UK I mean my sister ran over
everyone's run away for a stupid reason
yeah you can't legally back the kid up
oh everyone ever you know what I mean
every 15 year old girl has you know yeah
run away run away from the parents to
run away yeah that's just a teenager
thing yeah yeah
wow okay so you they say she's in foster
care sorry what happens next
um this is in foster care
um
then they want the youngest the younger
sibling they want a sister the younger
one so they start doing what's called
um parental assessments
to see what I'm like as a parent with
regards to caring for the children okay
so over the past year it's all been
about trying to take the younger one out
the house because
um after the last time we went to the
court system
and I know the biggest upset to the
children was the mother
um not letting them have a decision and
not let them think for themselves and
um you know forcing them to stay with
her when they didn't want to so when
this all kicked off and rosemary she's
called Rosemary my 15 year old
um when this was all kicked off a few
days later I found out Rosary says she
doesn't want to come home
she's happy where she is
um and I said
not something I'm happy with but but
she's at foster care now
Susan foster care not with the mum and
she said she's happy where she is
and that she didn't want to return home
I'll say is okay
not what I want to hear but I'm not
going to force a child to do something
that they don't want to do hopefully
she'll come round or is that just what
they said this is I've never spoke to
her I've never been allowed to speak to
her this is all just relayed information
wow so you don't even know if that's
actually what I don't know if this is
what's actually being said or what I
don't know what's being said I do know
that they've told her that I don't
wonder
and that um rejection that
um
I've got some sort of
um resentment issues with her because of
what's going on and she's never welcome
home again and and all these sorts of
things
and I said well no wonder she didn't
want to see is if this is what you tell
now this is discuss how do you know if
they said that to her they said that's
all about what they told me this is what
we're telling them wow
it's all out in the open they told you
that this is what they're telling your
daughters
which is so stupid because every I'm
sorry death will take you back after
anything like that you love your kid so
it's like you don't even like I've said
every kid teenager said stupid to
their dad before Oh 100 like he's never
gonna not take you back or never a lot
of a letter or even or even hold it
against you no no definitely not my
sister moved into a box one time really
yeah she I forgot why I was over
something stupid
that she came back that day but you know
what I mean but it's like they're
legally wow okay so they tell you
they're telling her this yes yes wow
it's a very blatant with the way they
operate and the really not hiding
anything that just and
and I said that's sick I said that's
absolutely sick I said it's disgusting
and I'm pretty appalled with the way the
system works if you're telling a
vulnerable young girl in this situation
that that's what a dad's saying about us
and that's disgusting and sick wow
okay so then like what happens next uh
what happens next is
um like I said we go on for the over the
next year it was December so
um January February March all through
April up to December when the final
hearing was
um they've been coming out of the house
and talking to me and talking to
Gabriella you're you're younger the
youngest one yeah sorry and this is for
they they do this parental assessment
how often do they do the parental
assessment apparently this is just
routine and what happens in
circumstances no like how how often are
they over doing that like every week
every Fortnight every two weeks they
came every two weeks and what do they
just interview both of you uh nothing to
do with me they just go and talk to to
the child I used to go out and do some
shopping and just leave them in the
house and you don't know what they're
saying to them you don't know what
they're doing don't know what they're
saying
it's up to them I said I told them from
the starters there's anything you need I
won't get anywhere I'll stay out I'll go
away the house is yours help yourself to
what you want you know that Gabriella's
there just talk away anything you want
to talk to her about that's entirely up
to you
uh allow yourself no it's okay you don't
have to go out they used to say but I
felt a bit uncomfortable even though
it's my house yeah I felt a bit
uncomfortable you know thinking that
if I'm not there then they can see that
they've got full vein there's no
intimidation there's no coercion or
anything like that it's just those two
on their own they kind of come back at a
later date and say well Daddy was doing
this and Daddy was tugging her and and
so on and so forth I just wanted to be
out the way yeah nothing could be said
about my actions at all okay so then you
go to the final hearing and what do they
say
um when the final German and said
she needs to be removed from the house
the biggest concern is that we can't
talk to Gabriella no one can see her
they can't talk to Gabriella yeah that's
what they said that's that's why they
said the main reason for removing a fun
bike care to put in um
residential living she that won't allow
her to go into foster care this one the
put her in residential uh care home kind
of thing
and they said it has to be in there
because it's so concerning that nobody
can speak to Gabriella or talk to Mr
Dawson about things
wait I so they're saying that they
couldn't talk to her and no one else is
allowed to talk I'm just a no
one's been able to speak to her but
they'd been there every two weeks so
they just lied so they're just like
what's a residential care home it's like
um
a hotel
for children as opposed to just a house
so there's three four five six children
there as opposed to just one child in
foster care with a family it's tough as
opposed to a foster family
yeah
wow so they just took your other
daughter too they just took it away said
that um the one equipment residential
care until a minimum of 18 years of age
or until they say she's emotionally
capable of looking after herself
wow at 13 years old and what did she
what did your daughter say about all
this she broke down she was in
Aesthetics she was screaming crying
smashing things up just going absolutely
crazy distraught not understanding why
they would want to do this so your
daughter didn't she didn't want to go oh
no no she was dead set against it she's
absolutely distraught at the moment
being in residential care hates it and
how long has she been in there since
January
Wow since January
this is so crazy so I didn't I didn't
realize your wife wasn't even involved
in any of this
she became involved
um maybe two weeks after it all started
in April it was 28th of April or
something I got so maybe she got
involved in May after the school
contacted her and the local Authority
got hold of her as well
and everybody said from the start would
keep an eye on Mr Dawson because it was
strange how he had Soul preventive
responsibility I want to know why that
is and this that's why we're kept an eye
on them and I thought why when a court
has given me custody why would you find
out a problem why would that be
problematic or any kind of concern
yeah no but that's what they did
um
and when the wife got involved there was
all sorts of accusations coming out and
she says I had drugs forms in the house
I had my house searched by the police
okay
um what else did you come out with I'm a
murderer mass murderer who has dead
bodies buried all over the UK
um I'm part of an international crime
syndicate and that runs crime speeds
through Europe
[Music]
um
you have no criminal record I do have a
criminal record but from about 30 years
ago 20 years ago and there's nothing
like that there there's no what's the
criminal record criminal record was pet
these things odd possession of drugs I
had um theft
um I had a
I had a burglary on my criminal record
but there's no violence there there's no
robberies or
um what was the other one Museum heists
there's no new Museum heists or anything
there there's no excuse me killing
people how long has it been since like
you were convicted of anything you said
20 years well at least 20 yeah yeah okay
you see it she said you were doing
Museum heists yeah
yeah
okay so the wife comes in during all
this and has all these crazy accusations
against you too
Okay so
a little pretty sick some of the things
she came up with were pretty dumb sick
oh I think a massive murderer that's
pretty that's pretty crazy it is pretty
crazy George finds it to be true
um they found it to be the judged and
found your courses yep I believe that
you were mass murderer you just haven't
been caught with it
wait wait but did they say who you
murdered no
there's a lot just random people this is
random people how could how could they
believe because that's what I realized
about family court it's like a balance
of probabilities so it's like the judge
just has to find it to be true basically
he just has to find
um a slight probability that that could
be true yeah
yeah and so essentially they can just
accuse you of crimes with no evidence
yes yeah yeah it's meant to be
and everyone's based
but it's it's not it's not
I can't believe they just took your
daughter away the government and put
them in foster care you're the second
guy I've talked to that this has
happened to yeah or they just took away
the kid so
what did you what did you have
recordings of
um all of the mutants when they used to
come around the house okay
um to talk to me and I recorded any
instance that I've spoke to anybody with
regards to all of this and I've learned
from the past how things go with family
court uh Gabriella also made some
recordings at school when um a social
worker came in and seen a unannounced
she just turned up so she recorded that
conversation that she had there
but um every time we came to the house I
recorded it come on in would you like a
drink take a seat
and so on and so forth so when they're
saying in court no one can speak to
anyone I'm saying well I've got dozens
of recordings what do they say about the
recordings when you show it to them they
said that's my opinion
wait that's your opinion when you have
recordings of you yes leaving and giving
like and allowing them to talk to her
yes
is the court recorded too
um I think it is I haven't recorded it
but I think in general court proceedings
are recorded okay so I didn't go that
far just to record judges and recording
in court yeah well I'm just wondering
like what like you have on like what do
you have um I've got a recording of the
school and
um
the local Authority is saying now nobody
has any concerns with regards to the
Gabriella no one's saying she's been
abused everything's fine we've got no
worries at all and with the living
arrangements as well looked after she's
doing good in school the house is well
kept
um you're very polite and courteous when
we come round no one is even thinking
there's any kind of abuse going on with
regards to Gabriella
and then they go to court and say abuse
massive concerns have to get him out of
there wait and it speaks the school said
that they don't think that she's been
abused it was a meeting between myself
and the school Healthcare team okay and
the social worker
and then later the social worker said
that she believed that they're being
abused yes okay and you have that on
recording too
and that's inviting that's interesting I
put that in a report wow and the only
thing I have in recordings is all
positive it's all we don't understand
what the problem is everything's fine
there's no worries and then behind my
back
the reports that they're putting in the
courts are saying massive concerns abuse
going on she shouldn't be there
it was threatening me he threatened me
when I was in his house he was
aggressive he was abusive towards me and
all sorts of things that we're saying
and I'm like
but you look me Square in the eyes and
said I'd like to think I would do the
right thing in circumstances why are you
saying that I've threatened and I was
aggressive and abusive yeah you know I
don't get where you're coming from with
these things that's I just want to know
why like why are they you don't know I
don't know why so are the what are the
social workers like is it all women or
women yes girls just
um
and what about the judge he was a mom as
a man okay
and the judge was the one who decided to
take away your kids yes okay
and but the he was bait going off of the
evidence that there are evidence which
was the local Authority statements okay
and so because the local authorities
said that you're abusive
he then made the ruling that you were
yes do you think the Judge like knows
knows that they're full of
um yeah 100 you kind of listening to my
the way things went in court my
Barrister was coming out of love and
said it sounded lunatics they sound
crazy and a bit deranged with the way
they're going on because they're all
shouting and getting angry and
coming up with some outrageous things
and mindlessness saying well they just
sound ridiculous and you can see you're
not the person that's being described so
this is just you know kind of thing
and I and I'm like well I'm confident
because
it does sound crazy what they're saying
and they're all looking a bit unhinged
and you know and I'm not the person
they're saying you completely see that
I'm not some quiz
labeled me as
um split personality disorder borderline
personality disorder specifically
violent narcissistic
[Music]
um
a need for adoration
um and and a few other things there's a
couple of syndromes and stuff in there
that the labeled as with
um anger management issues
um issues with authority problems with
authorities in these things and I'm
thinking
I've just sat through a whole caucus
here with the authority and at no point
have I got angry or raised my voice or
being derogative or
said anything mean or nasty but they all
stood there shouting red face spittle
coming out you have an angry man Mr
Dawson you're an angry man
and I sat there at one point I said I
beg your pardon but you're the only one
not shouting yeah I've been nice and
polite to the whole thing I'm not at any
point last but temper
no one's seen me ever angry so why do
you keep saying I've got anger
management problems
so I just don't understand what like why
it's like why would the judge like what
incentive does he have I don't know but
one thing he did say was if the local
Authority write something down
then it's a hundred percent true
I can't be faulted and shouldn't be
questioned oh cool okay child services
okay so if the local Authority writes
something down they have to regard it as
true
no I'm not regardless of these two it
just is it is just fact wow when they
write something down
and recordings physical evidence is just
an opinion
wow yeah that's what he said
so essentially in that when local
Authority he's talking about social
services uh Social Services yeah okay so
essentially your first daughter they
said you were abusive because you told
her not to wear makeup and short skirts
to school yes she freaks out and the
school phones children the children
services over you not letting your
daughter wear makeup yes then they put
her in foster care do you know where
she's staying like do you know what
families
so you you don't get to know where your
daughter is no you don't get to know
who's raising her nope and I would
imagine as a young girl that like that's
not really a safe situation when you
have fast like you God knows who's
watching your daughter yeah
then then
and that was in
you haven't seen her in a year a year
yeah a year then three months ago or
then they start investigating you and
doing parental assessments every two
weeks for what six months for the
duration so for a year for March up
until December
okay so about eight months about eight
months and they come every two weeks and
you allow them to talk to your daughter
every two weeks she says she want your
dog your youngest daughter says she
wants to be with you
and they don't care basically yeah
because of the final hearing they said
she needs to be removed yes even though
you have
recordings of the school saying that
they don't think she was being abused
both both daughters did they say that
about or just your youngest uh just the
youngest okay
it was only ever her that anybody would
speak to me about
um
I was I wasn't allowed to attend
meetings that says will not letting you
attend meetings to know what's going on
with the kids we're not gonna
and let you participate in any kind of
um decision making when it comes to the
children we just don't want your part of
these things but when they went to court
they said Mr Dawson has been invited to
all
the meetings and he had nothing to say
about anything
wow so they they did not let you go to
any of the meetings about your oldest
daughter uh oldest or youngest
wait I'm sorry explain that one more
time so I I thought you had recordings
from the youngest daughter yes your
daughter took those yes oh she took
those okay that was nothing to do with
me oh okay so your youngest daughter so
they but they wouldn't let you in any of
the meetings no and I've got it in
writing as well because they emailed me
okay and said Mr Dawson's not to attend
any mutants I told them today by the
telephone that he's not to attend any
meetings which is crazy because you
don't know what they're saying to your
kids kids are really impressionable yeah
yeah so you have this third party that
now is influencing your kids
okay but you have recordings from your
youngest daughter saying basically the
school telling her that they don't think
she was abused
um it was a meeting between myself and
the social worker for my youngest
daughter and the school health care and
and we were talking
um about the welfare of the child and I
kept pushing and pushing what's the
concerns here I'm not getting what the
concerns are you around my house all the
time and it was me that told that to
that says we don't have any no one's
saying there's any kind of abuse going
on with Gabrielle no one's saying that
Mr Dawson and I'm like well what's all
this little thing
okay I don't get it
okay so then
um
then you so after you do this for about
eight months every two weeks they come
over then you go to court and they say
that you did not like you were abusive
towards the social worker yes it's very
difficult to understand because
simultaneously right
no one's been able to come around and
speak to anyone but at the same time
they're coming round and speaking and
I'm threatening them
an aggressive with them while they're
speaking notes I almost think they just
make up words so people are confused
like this like coercive control
manipulate all these words I think they
just make up words to confuse people
okay I can jump on board with that one I
can see them doing that
the
the weather went about things was like I
say it was just all out in the open
there was no secrecy or anything about
it
um because although they're telling me
one thing and everything and
everything's going along in One
Direction the go and say something else
behind your back but then when you say
why did did you they go yeah I said that
I'm gonna say but this isn't what's
happening can I have an example like
um
uh one social worker said she was in the
house one day
um and
I was totally detached from reality my
eyes glazed over and I was speaking to
people that weren't in the room
she said that my youngest daughter came
in the room at one point
and and said that she's got a letter
from her sister and I went ballistic
started getting angry and the child was
scared
um and I said
but that didn't happen
we've had a really good relationship I
don't get
why you just make that whole scenario up
out of thin air and put that in a report
for the courts I don't get why you would
say that and the response I keep getting
involved
I said it
wow and you recorded all this recorded
yeah and there's no evidence that that
even happened nothing all you get is
come on in would you like a drink how
are you doing uh I'll just go and get
Gabriella yep I'll leave them alone
thank you very much see you later and
then if you go to the judge they say
that
they he just says well we have to
believe this is true yeah
it's true
and I said but I've got the recordings
that's sure that's a lie that's just
your opinion Mr Dawson I said No it's
it's evidence that's what's cluster's
evidence wow and I'm the only one in
this whole case who's provided any kind
of evidence I've provided you with
emails I've provided you with reports
I've provided you with recordings yeah
and you don't wonder because what's
their evidence that you're abusing her
just what they say
wow because especially this is what I
don't understand when they accuse men of
abuse like most men can beat up any even
average guy doesn't go to the gym at all
can beat up a chick so it's like if
you're abusing her where are the marks
where are the where are the
and do they do they say it's physical or
do they say like emotional or like add
in some both and guys this is what they
do they expand the definition of a beat
like talking viewers they expand the
definition of abuse to basically put
anything in it so they'll say like
coercive it's like all these weird words
they just make up all of that is what
they're saying is classes abuse
emotional abuse mental abuse like what
is mental abuse it's like
uh calling someone fat
is mental abuse or emotional abuse
calling someone fat
um
I don't know
I'm not quite sure to be honest because
there won't elaborate on anything right
well the color really you know they
couldn't elaborate on anything it's like
when I leave here and I'll go away
um we've had a really good interaction
I'll go into she attacked me with
glasses and bottles and this that right
and you can say but I've got the the
recording to say that that's not true
and you say but Brian why did you say
that our note's not true so I don't want
anything to do with it I'm just like no
I'm aware got no answers to that one you
know and then people saying nah that
record is just your opinion Pearl he
said it so it's true
wow that's so crazy
social worker believes they're being
abused and then they gave you a bunch of
mental diagnoses too yes I went and
spoke to somebody for a couple of hours
a psychologist was it I think it was
there okay but this is from the social
workers this is from the court appointed
okay professional court appointed
professional okay
a core appointed professional
um
and they then said you would split
personality disorder yes yes
but I'd imagine they wouldn't let you go
to a third party and check no no they
just said the court
it's just so weird to me I don't
understand why
there must be money in this somewhere
with the hospital yeah
um you know each and every person along
the lines going to make a little bit of
money you know someone's going to get
out of the field and speaking to people
and get a desk job because they did so
good and they've saved a child and
you know there's all advantages
they just tell themselves they're like
saving the kids I'm assuming so
okay so then what have you done since
then like what's happened since
um since the final year in in December
we have um
we had the meeting in January to see
what was going to happen with my
youngest child Gabriella
um and since then nothing's happened not
allowed to appeal against anything you
can't appeal it no it wouldn't let me
appeal
wow Point Blank refused wasn't allowed
to appeal against the final orders or
anything
wow
wasn't allowed to question anything that
had been said against us every time we
brought up a question the person we were
asking just said I don't know it wasn't
me ask somebody else
a nice listeners like but you're
personally you not your co-workers but
you personally have brought this case to
make findings so you must know what
findings you want
don't know
so what we're here for and why are we in
college if nobody knows why we're here
so there's no way you can even legally
fight this
stripped me from all of us
wow so they took your two daughters away
now you don't like I just can't even
imagine not knowing who's raising or
around my kids
like that's that's gotta be just because
you don't know what creeps are in these
systems you know and you don't know it's
very terrifying I've got a lot of
experience uh with negativity from from
the system uh when I was a child growing
up there was a family across the road
um and they had like 12 kids that would
just have a child after child after
child but the father was a social worker
he was a big six and a half he was a big
barely guy but he seemed like a nice guy
as well and he worked for the exact
um
services that are dealing with me the
same office and everything he's in jail
for pedophilia he wasn't there to help
children he was there abusing children
wow and the same people who defended him
the same company the same work
colleagues are the ones that have done
this to me
so it's the same people that were
defending him
when he was accused and now he's in jail
he's in jail he's been there for a few
years now as far as I'm aware
um but it's the same same house the same
business the same company the same no
way yeah because you have like uh it's
regional you have Northumberland the
Newcastle County councils and he he
already lived in Newcastle he worked in
Northumberland which is the team that
are dealing with me and he was caught
out like I said being the pedophile and
doing things with children he shouldn't
have been doing
yeah because it's like what I mean you
have the incentive like this is just how
I think it's like why would someone want
to be a foster parent yeah I mean there
are the people that actually genuinely
want to help but you got to get Creeps
in there too there's no way you don't
well
as I've been talking with my eldest
daughter who's been really good for all
this we're talking about it and my
youngest daughter has gone somewhere to
a concert or something with one of the
staff members some man
uh mid-20s 30 years old has taken my 13
year old daughter out until two in the
morning to go to a concert with nobody
else around
which I think oh I'll find out how did
you find that out my daughter told us
wait so wait I thought you haven't been
able to talk to your daughters I'll meet
up with the same my daughters well I
haven't been able to talk to the eldest
daughter at all no correspondence the
youngest one you've been the youngest
one she still has a mobile phone so she
can still send text messages and
Facebook messages
okay and you found out that she was
taken to a concert by a guy it's coming
up in a week or two weeks the concert so
and I said who are you going with
and she's had a name and I said is that
one of the other kids in the house who
says no it's stuff and I'm like well how
old is this man
she says Ollie late 20s 30 kind of
and I'm like oh okay
um I don't know how comfortable I am
with this baby girl kind of thing yeah I
don't know what to say to her I don't
want to say you're not going yeah
there's more evidence of abuse yeah I'm
abusing her
um
but I don't like to force my children
anyway I don't like the come down on the
menu we are like trying to educate them
and let them make their own minds up uh
obviously to a certain extent right and
come to the wrong decision I'd imagine
if she was at home that would just be a
no oh 100 it would just be it now but
it's like some mountains up the door
says I'm taking the kid off yeah no no
that's not happening no that doesn't
happen yeah what kind of concert is it
yeah I don't know some some man's
concept I don't know I don't know I just
you know just there's like weird I don't
know I was just wondering like there's
one coming up she's not in a weird music
or anything yeah it'll just be some like
Ed Sheeran or oh something like that
kind of concept you know what I mean but
it finishes like one o'clock in the
morning she's saying we won't be back
till early hours and I'm thinking
hmm I don't know yeah it doesn't sound
too good this early hours of the morning
that's like you're powerless like what
it stripped me of all power I have no
say in a life whatsoever
like what is this done to you like purse
like I'd imagine because what do you do
for work I don't know if I uh installer
uh we do windows and doors okay
installing Windows and Doors
um and has it been like hard I mean I I
can't even imagine like working while
all this is going on it's absolutely
hectic absolutely destroy we've all been
it's so hard to concentrate it really is
um
it's
I can't really describe it it's like a
hollow emptiness and I'm just going
through the motions every day just
getting up and doing things and
and just as I am and I have to be there
for if she calls if she messages I have
to be there to be all nice and happy and
yeah confident and encouraging for her
to to be the pillar for someone strong
who's there all the time and reliable so
I have to kind of just deal with my own
emotions separately and yeah be someone
else for my eldest daughter someone else
for my youngest daughter I mean
you know I just have to be all different
people at the moment and not understand
who I am well because I always hear like
why don't men like this is like when I
talk to people that aren't aware of this
that the question they always says like
why don't men just fight for their kids
why don't men just try like it's the man
the reason they don't get custody or the
reason they can't get their kids is
because they just don't fight oh we
fight we fight a lot
um
I was spending tens of thousands of
dollars on Australia monthly
um paying for her to have visits with
the children the court said that she
must avenge it and pay for visitation
she wouldn't so I had to pay it and I
think it was costing me about five and a
half maybe six thousand dollars
per visit to arrange a visit from her
wow yeah so we do fight and we do try
and do what's right
you know we are fair I was fair all the
way I never stopped the mother from
seeing the children and like I said when
the such extends to to make a meeting
happen and she didn't turn up for the
first one didn't want to go to it
rearranged it and then expected me to
keep paying every time so she canceled
an appointment and they've got the
appointment I was like no you have to
pay if you're going to keep canceling
you know you're about to pay for all of
it never mind just canceling things
uh which obviously she wasn't happy
about
but um
did everything I could I went through
the legal procedures I did everything
right I was
picking all the boxes and doing anything
that was at my disposal who do it just
doesn't mean anything well and you
couldn't the only way you could have
avoided this is if she wasn't in school
but that's not really realistic for the
average thing with that homeschool his
kids yeah but you but you see why I see
why so many people are doing that
nowadays because this is nuts yes it is
like you can't avoid the entire system
no
how much money have you spent trying to
like on lawyers probably the last
to keep custody of your daughters
it's been a lot I don't know an exact
figure like rough it's okay
75 000. wow 75 000.
and that's probably more than you make
in a year right or about what you make
we were making good money in Australia
we had our own company and so we
we were living well we had a very good
income of that okay well because some
because a lot of times they'll say like
oh why don't they just go to court one
and you did fight but some men choose
not to because you know the average guy
makes forty thousand a year like it was
he supposed to spend most
all of that money on court yeah and even
if you won it's not like you would get
that oh we're sorry you had to waste all
this money here here's some
reimbursements yeah nothing you got
nothing at the end of it I just wipe
your hands so who who are the people
like who was the judge on this case okay
are you allowed to say names or like
um I don't know it depends I don't mind
yeah I'll name and shame everyone yeah
but because they know what they've done
they're doing the best to gag me so I
kind of think about certain things
um the judge handed me the paper and
said I'm going to put a gag order on you
so you cannot mention anything that's
taking place in court wow so you have a
gag order yeah I said well if that
doesn't show good I don't know what it
is I says but I don't have any
intentions of repeating words that were
reciting in court my story is going to
be about why we're in court in the first
place in the social services I've acted
throughout all of this
Social Services again applied to get a
gag order Social Services got a gag
order and try to try to apply for the
gag order 1B so I couldn't speak about
anything at all they're trying to get an
injunction so I wasn't allowed anywhere
near my children just because they might
not know yeah what's a gag order uh keep
me quiet so I'm not allowed to speak
about any events or any
any happenings throughout but it's like
if there's nothing to hide then why why
do they need you to be quiet I'd imagine
they would be proud to get an abuser
away from their kid from his kids right
wouldn't that be a good thing well you
would think so and I asked them the
exact same question
they've got no response wow so you can't
even you can't even legally talk about a
lot of this stuff technically
technically wow
have you talked to like fathers for
Justice at all
uh I don't think I have no I looked at
the website I'm familiar with the name I
looked at the website news then wouldn't
give advice and recommend solicitors in
this that
um but by the time I got under there my
court case and all that was finished
yeah and I was refused to write to any
kind of appeals or anything like that so
I thought
not much good going to them yeah
sometimes he has like he's just done it
for so long that sometimes there's ways
around stuff I don't really know but
it's crazy to me that you're not even
allowed to like speak about like why do
you think they want to silence you
because they know they've done wrong
they know they have
who is the judge on this case judge
Hardy judge Hardy okay and that's in
Newcastle Newcastle yes okay and
who are the social services people
involved there was one lady called Janet
Ingham
and the very first one that came around
was like an emergency worker I think she
was called Agnes or something I don't
recall her name yes okay
um but the the first one Judy's solicit
Social Services I came around who was
allocated as the children's social
worker was called Suzanne Nicholson
and I met her once do you think that the
court is sexist against men 100
percent
do you think you would experience the
same thing if it was your ex-wife as
opposed to you
uh no women would not
face the same as what men are through
this
um my ex-wife
she was stripped of prevent
responsibility which is unheard of in
England
um
she's living with a man at the moment
who has a common criminal record for a
lot of violence
um
breaking into people's homes and
splashing them up like home invasion
kind of thing he's got a lot of uh that
one is is criminal record
um the mother has told all the children
I don't like you
in fact I hate you I want nothing to do
with you don't love you
um told them to
F off
[Music]
um when the younger two children in
Australia went to speak to us upon the
police on them and have them removed
she blocked them on social media and on
a phone so they couldn't get in touch
with her in any way
um and the judge said what have you done
per
like encourage any kind of relationship
between mother and children
and I said well
I was paying thousands of dollars for
that I have visits with them
and I told them to give her wings and
and emails and what have you but that's
hard to do when you when you're blocked
you know I submitted the pictures uh
screenshots and uh what what have you of
um your blocked account deleted and this
that the other to show that she's
blocked them on on on the account and on
a telephone again that's just my opinion
and I didn't do anything to encourage a
relationship between mother and children
and your youngest daughter
um has she told you how Foster or not
foster care um the Residential Care Home
is has she given you any like updates on
it yeah we know where that is yeah we do
straight away because of all this stuff
on your phones these days the truck
things I'm not good with technology but
the kids are so she had these track
things on saying this is where they are
this is where they've taken us and I
think it's an hour and a half
down the motorway of the Tucker now what
is she saying like about like the living
conditions has she like is she all right
uh she seems okay safe enough
and would just
I guess it's just free win for the
children that can basically do what the
one she doesn't have any bed times uh
she doesn't have to eat any specific
meals
um
no curfews on phone usage or or anything
like that they could literally just
taking a
I mean that's horrible for a young girl
I mean to let us do whatever we want at
13 14. yeah wow this I thought
um
self-destruct it if I had to do whatever
I wanted at 13. I know right yeah yeah
I'm like
you know because that's who your parents
are there for to not guidance correct
yeah because uh at 13 you're just like
mad at the world for no reason yeah like
you know you've got that chip on your
shoulder yeah yeah like the entitled you
know you're just like yeah yeah it is
yeah and so if you don't have like
parents to Reign you in I can't even
imagine but parents aren't allowed to
anywhere and it's abusive a child should
be allowed to do watch it once because
she knows what she wants at that age and
one of my main concerns was the school
were pushing
um
ah they're pushing for the young
children have sexual relationships
what yeah and I said that's a big No-No
to me and they said you're not letting
them develop at an age-appropriate rate
this school wait wait the school was
pushing for your kids to have sexual
relationships yeah they give my 15 year
old who was 14 at the time and condoms
no yeah and I'm saying who on Earth has
the right to give my child condoms
because I don't believe 14 year olds
should be sexualized in any way that's
not good at all and that's not how I'm
raising my children that's abusive
you're controlling
you're not letting them be who they want
to be that's what they said yeah yeah
wow Child Services backed that up and
said yep
that's abusive you can't stop them doing
these things
because you you
why would they want a sexual light like
why would you want to give a kid condoms
that's a question I asked at 14.
like they shouldn't even be doing that
at 14. well it's no wonder these girls
are starting earlier and earlier and
earlier yeah because if the school's
literally showing them how to yeah wow
yeah
wow so the thing is though my daughters
um
she's not worldly so when it comes to
um everyday events like you know 16 17
year olds might encounter where they are
being a bit flirtatious and we are
experimenting
she's knocking she's not ready for that
sort of thing yeah and it shows because
um she started being sexually harassed
in school and she was sexually assaulted
in school as well
um and the report from the school they
keep a timeline she's sexually assaulted
I'm not loud enough oh they won't wait
wait okay okay she was sexually
assaulted in school yes and they won't
tell the parent who
didn't tell me it happened
no you made a note they have what's
called a chronology and anything that
happens in school the teachers know that
down and it specifically said do not
tell Dad
why yes and I said how am I meant to
understand the mental
um position that my daughter's in at the
moment if you're keeping things like
that for me how do I know where she is
mentally so she was sexually assaulted
and harassed and they didn't was that
during the year they took her from you
after she left bacteria or about the cut
about the time just prior to just after
that it was about that time when that
happened
so they're they're
telling the kids not to tell the parents
yep it was in the school and North to
tell other teachers
don't let them know this has happened
that's the most up thing I've
ever heard I'll think that's disgusting
why why would you not want the parent to
know especially if she was assaulted
then don't don't you want them to help
her
apparently enough or maybe even avoid
the person that did it
hardly enough wow so the school was
sexualizing your daughter she was
assaulted
harassed then they refused to tell you
yes
and then said you were abusing her yes
because you wanted her to not wear
makeup yes
yes it's against school policy for
children to wear makeup in school
so she's not even allowed to work not
even allowed to wear makeup to school
it's like this is like a game this is so
weird
and this is what I've had to come to
terms with and try and understand what's
going on with my children
when she was born she was born with a
heart murmur and uh bunker like this and
growing up every year around Christmas
time when the weather got cold should be
hospitalized because she has a weakened
respiratory system yeah and she can't
deal with all sorts of things so when it
comes to the winter
um which it was I think it was -2
degrees the day that the Children's
Services were in my house this day in uh
in March the end of March and she can't
deal with it she needs to wear weather
report for your clothing
and when they spoke to me about it
saying why won't you let her wear the
skirts and I said firstly I don't think
uh it's appropriate for the type of
skirts we're talking about because the
women's skirt you can't see you don't
know they're wearing them because the
Blazer comes down they just right up oh
they're so short they're so short and I
said I don't approve of that kind of
thing editing uniform
no it's against School regulations
oh okay but again the school are saying
it's a piece of everyone that I have
school it's great that short
and she does wear skirts I love her to
wear skirts it's nothing to do maybe she
wants to wear skirt wear skirts like
this this would be fine right absolutely
yeah yeah spiritual dresses in fact
Rosemary was always in skirts and
dresses she was very feminine very
feminine always in skirts and dresses
that's a bit so many pictures of her in
dresses and skirts and shorts and
bikinis not bikinis sorry my Boomer mind
uh the like leotard bathing costume yeah
kind of thing yeah lots of pictures and
she is allowed to wear these things just
when it's minus two degrees outside
because she has a weak and respiratory
system she needs to wear weather report
for your clothing wow nah should we have
to handle my face no no like that and I
thought wow how condescending that
and I said it's not an opinion when a
child gets ill you have a medical record
saying look at them the only time
Rosemary has never needed any kind of
medical attention was when she was in my
care previous to that when I'm out
working and my mother looks after her
she's in the hospital and then out of
doctors all the time I had full custody
I concentrated on my family
no medical issues whatsoever she gets
removed from my care and she's got chest
infections she's off school for weeks on
end and it's like wow didn't I tell you
she needs to wear weather report for
your clothing
you know and I'm trying to explain to
him that making a child by weather
report with your clothing isn't some
form of abuse
you know it's worldwide that we couldn't
really go do the the shops have the
seasonal wear come winter time to get
rid of the shorts and stuff and they put
the woolly jumpers and jackets in come
summer then they've got the swim stuff
and again it's it's what people do it's
called good parent and as far as I'm
concerned right so make sure your
children are wearing weather appropriate
clothing right it's abuse and the second
she gets to take them off she's ill
wow wow and no one's bothered about the
the welfare the physical welfare well
it's like they don't even care about the
welfare of the kid they just wanna
make me look a bad guy and get them away
yeah
it's almost like virtue signaling like
so they can just feel like they took
they they saved the daughters even
though they're like harming them yeah
yeah they've caused so much damage to my
family they really have my children were
in a very vulnerable position anyway
after all but being through with the
mother uh rejecting them and the the
court case we went through there and all
the stress and me being in detention
again it was through
um March through December and I was in
the Detention Center I was away from the
children that I couldn't physically hold
them I wasn't allowed to wait you were
in a Detention Center in Australia yeah
before we came back to the UK
why are we in a Detention Center because
um my Visa got refused oh because of the
Visa right we were returning back to the
UK right but without saying anything
she'd gone to the courts to apply for
custody and put a no fly on the children
right so I got to the airport with the
children
and got stopped and says no there's an
active court case that I didn't know
about I'm like what court case oh well
you must know I says I don't know and it
was a child custody case that was going
on so no one's allowed to leave the
country
uh the children got Australian citizens
so they were okay to stay there but I
didn't have a Visa and instead of giving
me a bridging Visa so I could stay there
while my cultivation goes on like they
do with criminals to put me in a
detention center and says no you're not
coming back into Australia
wow yeah so you just fought for like
three or I forgot how long you said one
year two years it was the year in
Australia I thought yeah yeah and then
the time over here but then you so you
just gotten your kids they just went
through all this stuff yeah you won and
you went to England and then the school
comes in
and then
basically do that just they I mean they
did they just took your kids yeah
did you ever I know there's a way you
can request all the files that the
school has on you
it's um because sometimes blindfold I
know what it is
it's um Freedom of Information yeah yeah
you can apply for that but I got it
that's how I found out that had been
sexually assaulted
it was needed as part of the Court
bundle yeah so the court says we need
the chronology from the school to find
out what's been happening at the school
um but obviously nothing that well
presented they always turned up on time
works always done the polite encourages
lovely young children and no issues at
all and but it wasn't until that that
information became available but I found
out what exactly had been going on with
the kids at school and you know what's
crazy people will still tell me that the
court doesn't discriminate against man
that it's like perfectly Fair it is
crazy because I'll have guy after guy
after guy come in here tell their
stories I don't have women asking to
come in here I've been doing this
documentary I'm waiting for all the
women that have this equal experience
yeah it's only men yeah it's like they
treat you guys as sub-human especially
and they really don't
I mean if the if they really cared about
the welfare of the children why don't
men get custody off the bat because
Mountain raised better kids than women
it's really clear eventually that's the
case yes yeah and it's also
um statistically proven that I think
it's like 75 percent of all child abuse
cases the mothers
75 percent of all child abuse 75 the
mothers has an involvement in it
um I can't remember the exact figures it
was yeah however many percent just a
mother the mother than somebody else and
then it was the father and somebody else
and then the father was the least likely
to be committing any kind of abuse
against the children but the the most
likely suspect was the mother she was
always the perpetrator and the step dads
I've heard is a really common one yeah
step dad yeah which is why it's mother
and someone else
so mother is a big perpetrator yeah
rather than somebody else is a big chunk
of it and then the next section down is
farther than somebody else which will be
the mother and then the smallest case of
child abuse perpetrators is the father
yeah you guys are always labeled as
abusers always labeled as the abuse
and like you say children benefit a lot
more from a single parent household
raised by a father than they do a mother
no they do they do but it's it's so
crazy because men only get custody 10 to
20 of the time yeah and it's like it
should at least be 50 50. and if they
really if they really care that's my
thing if like if they really cared about
the welfare of the child why would you
not go off of the evidence of who raises
better children yes and in all honesty
it probably would be better for the
mother in terms of like
you know it would women need men to look
after them in my in my opinion like a
personal opinion but it probably would
be easier for them to get remarried and
like move on with their life you know if
the father had custody yeah you know
because women are much more likely to
date like single fathers than single
mothers yes so I don't like I honestly
think it's better for everybody if the
fathers get custody off the bat or at
least make it 50 50. yeah but it's not
even considered it's just push push push
towards the mother yeah it happened in
my case despite the fact she was
stripped of any preventive
responsibility it was push push push to
get the kids to the mother really yeah
pushing pushing pushing
Rosemary is getting sent back to
Australia
no yeah we're putting her back over to
Australia to go and be collected on that
side by a mother and this Terence blog
when it's there wait so Rose Rosemary is
the older who's 15 now should be 16 in
August so should we make her own mind up
anyway and go where she wants
but they're pushing at the Australian
saying we want this we want that we're
going to send them over to Australia
because uh obviously I'm rejecting and I
want nothing to do with that is the
narrative so the only option left
because she doesn't want to be in foster
care
is the mother wow I was sending them
over to the mother with this block who
no one knows anything about
um it was a violent history
they've got a dog in the house which has
bitten one of the other children's face
and for the family that's all fine happy
with dangerous dogs and Violent Men
let's get the kids over there anomaly
that doesn't make any sense to anybody
she stripped of it for a reason here and
now you're trying to push the kids to go
back to the mother and we don't even
know who this man is how do you know
that
which that that they're trying to
because I thought you couldn't talk to
Rosemary you know what they said in
court that's what they're telling the
judge we wanted to go with the mother
wow they're very open about things will
not hiding it it'll be sneaky behind
your back and then when you say what's
this will go and
wow
yeah who is they that's Social Services
Social Services yeah right why like why
don't don't they want the best interest
of the child like what's your what's
your take on it it's just money it's
um I think the one the easiest option
out of anything I don't think the one
the truth
um or what's best for anybody in the
circumstances I think they just want
what's the easiest procedure to go
through wipe your hands with it and see
you later
which is why there's a lot of um
sad stories come out of yeah the the
system with regards to children because
they're not really looked after the the
interests aren't that hard
what would you say to your daughters if
you could talk to them
um
I would just tell him that they would
always be loved 100 there's never going
to be a time in my life when I would
ever reject uh any of the children and
there's always time in life if ever the
children want to come and see me or talk
to me Dad's always there that's what
dad's for he is there to bring up his
princess he's there to bring up his
children to be strong independent women
uh who can look after themselves and are
going to prosper in life I'm always
going to want what's best for the for
the kids and I've always got a hug there
for them no matter how long it's been or
what's happened or been said
what impact has this had on your
personal life
um must have been pucked and I find it
very difficult to interact with any kind
of friendship group because
um
I've done bonds
I don't know it's very difficult to talk
about a situation with just friends or
just people
um you know I'm very secluded these days
I I don't want the interaction and I
don't want uh the attention uh whether
it's good or bad attention I
I'm just you know if I'm not working I'm
just in the house on my own I don't want
to speak to anyone don't want to see
anyone I don't go anywhere I don't do
anything
I'll I'll get washed push my teeth go to
bed wake up repeat
a lot of men like end up taking their
own lives in this situation have you
ever thought about that
um I totally get where they're coming
from because it has pushed me to a very
low point
um I'm not really
um an emotional kind of guy you know I'm
not
um I don't know
I'm very
masculine when it comes to my emotions
everything's kept inside of me and I
don't show anything to anyone you know I
deal with it and as it needs to be dealt
with I'll logically think of what's
happening and deal with the situation at
the time but at the moment
I find it very difficult to contain my
emotion and you know and I find myself
sometimes just in the evenings uh just
little reminders or just it's quiet
there's no one there and I can feel
myself becoming very emotional and and I
have to distract myself from that
you know talking to you today I find it
very difficult you know sometimes it
gets a bit when I'm talking it gets a
bit closer I can feel myself getting a
bit anxious and a bit emotional about
things but
you know it's it's just one of those
things that
I never thought I would ever experience
and the emotions I'm feeling through it
or emotions I never thought I would the
new to me and it's confusing to try and
keep things together and work them all
uh where where my life keeps going in a
positive direction
you never thought it would you would be
the one to have this happen to you
definitely not definitely not no never
thought that it would happen
um I took on four children uh from a
previous marriage and treated them like
my own and even when I had my biological
children and there was no special
treatment no one was ever put first
um my princess was was
um the youngest for my wife's previous
four she was always my princess
um and it wasn't a segregation thing it
was just that's what she was to me she
was the youngest girl at the time when
I've watched her grow up she was always
my little princess my biological
children and they weren't my princess
you know they weren't that person and so
although I love them all the same
everyone was individual and got treated
differently
um but the weren't tread differently as
far as emotional support and any kind of
prevental guidance or advice would go
they were all treated the same and they
were all looked upon by me as all being
my children
did the court ever ask for their
testimony if you're a crazy abuser
wouldn't the other kids know
and the wood and but
um one of the things that my wife came
out with
in the court case in Australia was
her second eldest daughter
my wife said the daughter didn't but the
wife said that I touched her boob
when we were all in a in a house
altogether
and that was the top and bottom of it
all that was her way of trying to
Blacken my name over there at this time
that you mentioned that this time when
we went to the court case yeah she
actually claimed that I raped one of the
children
wow and everyone said
when's this happened or years ago why is
this never ever we mentioned everywhere
you went through Court last time when
you lost your children why wouldn't you
pull that one out the heart then
so this time we progressed from touching
one of them on a boob to actually rape
and someone I think the words were
digitally
digitally ripped is the terminology they
used which I don't want to look into it
I'm not really interested in what what
that kind of thing was but that was
something the ex-wave pulled out the
heart to in this court case
well and did they even ask the daughter
no no no just taking the truth
yeah the judge actually asked the local
authorities throughout the proceedings
how do you want me to make findings on
that
and it's meant to be non-biased what
does that even mean how do you want me
to make findings on that because the
it's called a fact-finding hearing okay
and they're saying this is what we're
seeing the years we need you to find in
our favor
and um he's gone through all these
things
um
like
oh there was so many she claimed that um
I was arrested in Spain we lived in
Spain for a couple of years she claimed
I was arrested there
um for stabbing someone with a knife and
the local Authority had been checking
for I think six months they said they'd
been checking uh talking to the Spanish
police and so on and so forth no records
of anything ever happening and this is
at one point when the judgments or how
am I making these findings went oh
that's truth and he said okay then
and he made the founding to be true that
happened
same with the um the museum heists like
I'm some kind of George Clooney fella
you know
um
stealing artwork or something I don't
know what it is I meant to have done but
some kind of Museum Heist and again the
judges have forgotten the evidence nor
have we checked this with the police has
it even happened with check there's no
reports of it happening at all
and he said so how do you want us to
find this oh yes as truth okay then well
and I'm like wow you cannot ask that
you're the judge who's meant to be
non-biased and these proceedings you
can't ask them so what do you want us to
do here how do you want us to make
refinance you can't ask that they Supply
the evidence in you as a judge are meant
to make findings
but he asked them all right how do you
want us to make it even though the
police are saying it's rubbish we've got
no record of it anywhere what do you
want us to do with that kind of thing oh
yeah I was Truth for finding it as truth
and you say okay then
wow yeah does this change your like the
way you view women and like dating I
gotta imagine you're very preoccupied
but I'm just thinking this was me
I would never date again yeah I would
like never does that
I kind of see myself being interested in
any kind of relationship yeah with women
at the moment with my mind Fame I have
no interest in that since the day I left
my ex-wife I've had no interest in that
yeah
um you know my focus with the children
and then now my focus is still the
children but in a different way
I don't trust
and when another relationship fully I
couldn't open myself up again to another
person uh for something like this to be
happening again it's just not right it's
yeah you know and then women will say
then go where's all the good men gone
well why won't men date us what's wrong
with me what's wrong you know yeah I'm a
10 out of 10 million it's like well
because I get a lot of you know
petrified
yeah well I get a lot of like hate
because they think I hate women you know
yeah yeah but it's but it's like I just
listen to these stories and I'm like I I
don't know how
men can avoid this like there's no way
for men to interact with women without
having a potential consequence legally
yes and you know it's easy to say oh
that not all women do that and that's
true not all women will but it's like
any woman can
and I think
I think um
the reason like I want to bring a lot of
guys that have gone through this like
gone through this is like people will
just say oh it's just in cells it's like
men that can't get women but I'm like no
it's normal guys with normal jobs it's
like it's not what they're they're
painting it out to be these just guys
that are just like complaining and
whining about nothing yeah I don't think
it's just that I think the way women go
on it's very scary yeah for men you know
it's
I mean how how do you know which woman
will and which woman wants you don't
you're rolling the dice and you take an
accountable yeah you know and a lot of
men have a lot to lose men work a very
hard jobs sometimes and they strive to
build what they have and then
for the sake of just letting a woman in
it could all just be gone like that and
you think
what's the worth is is the chance worth
it meeting a new person yeah you know
because you don't know when you first
meet someone that this is a decent
person and someone I want to spend my
life with all you know is it's a
potential partner and that's it you know
nothing else and you don't want to take
the chance well and they also don't know
like because they'll say oh well it's
easy to tell which women will or which
women won't
it's not no yeah yeah I mean because I
think what and and it's kind of what I
would say is like kind of victim blaming
in a way yeah you know because they'll
we'll say for ages like you shouldn't
blame a woman if something happens to
her right but if something happens to a
guy they're the first to blame the man
yeah well you should have known it's his
own fault and you know like I've had
guys come in where
they're really like the girl had all the
like typical green flags where like she
wasn't too old she had no previous kids
she had no like none of the typical like
red flags they would say and she still
switches up one day and the way I equate
it is like you know male female like um
evil is spite like I think that's the
worst thing about women is we're very
like one socially manipulative and
spiteful just like I think the worst
thing about men is they can be very like
aggressive right like women can be
socially aggressive but men can be like
physically aggressive like if you get a
Man Too angry or kill somebody yeah and
but basically what the government is
doing is giving women a legal gun
yes to like to be the worst parts of the
of us right like it's like if we took
you at the angriest or any guy the
angriest he's ever been with another man
and gave him a gun and said you can
legally kill him they might you know
what I mean there's no consequence here
um you know and I always think like okay
I might not be a thief but if every day
I see everybody stealing
and every day I see the thieves not
getting in trouble you know
at some point they at some point they
might do it yeah and that's what I see
with women is like it's like you take
women at our very worst which who one is
a warm and a worse person than in a
breakup exactly that's interesting we're
just like when is a man a worse person
when he's like drunk fighting at a bar
you know like or like the most angry
he's ever been and you give us a legal
gun
with which also women are super
susceptible to propaganda and then you
like put propaganda in the schools and
call everything abuse and convince us
that we were abused which I mean we
believe anything yes you know we're so
dumb it's like we believe the trans
stuff like you think that's men it's
women you know what I mean so they just
they just convince us of damn near
anything yeah and then allow us to
believe that we're in the right because
we have all these systems backing us
yeah all that but designed to support
the women and then able and the women
and like you say if people are getting
away with things all the time and the
benefit and from that yeah why would the
stop well it's like you if you were the
mass murderer and you killed like the
person that you hate the most in the
world and the whole everyone said you
were so great for doing that you were
the best man for killing that man you
should you know what I mean like and
they have all these systems and society
that rewards them for doing it it's like
what what why wouldn't the guy is gonna
damn near be delusional and now keep
doing it yeah and that's like what I see
happening to women yeah is that we just
keep rewarding this horrible Behavior
yes it's like yeah and so even even
women that maybe didn't start off as
evil they become it
because it's a kind of social
indoctrination yeah I think uh
it's like
if someone just comes up and Taps you on
the arm it's not going to do anything
but if someone sits there and constantly
Taps you on the arm suddenly you're
going to start getting a bit numb
they're going to start getting a
consequence to that action yeah and I
think it's the same society when women
are being
coached almost by certain people and and
opinions forced on them to tell them
that they are victims and that they're
you know that they should act out in the
way that they're doing it's going to
happen the one day that woman is going
to turn around and act like that and
she's going to get rewarded for it well
and they started so young like they do
it in the schools they'll tell women
like I had a girl come on the show and
say that she was coerced into sex what
the is coerced I was like what do
you mean you're coerced yeah and
basically like coerced as if a guy if
you say no to sex and a guy pushes it
what guy isn't gonna push it that's like
if I say no to buying a car and the car
salesman pushes it yeah you've been
coerced into buying a car then that yes
yes and I'm just like
so now you were co-work like it's but
it's basically under the threat of
violence like that's the the the caveat
but you can say that it's under the
threat of violence because men are
stronger than you yeah so that you felt
like he would do something but that if
he didn't
which kind of goes back like and so it's
like the the feminists bring all these
words in they like won they they ruined
the meaning of words so rape abuse they
like they like ruin the meaning because
they make it everything so they make
like rape me nothing abuse me which is
really offensive to women that about
women correct yeah and so then they
bring in all these like words that I
don't even understand what they mean and
they bring in all that's why I hate
people that talk too smart it makes me
not trust you because I'm just like what
can you just talk in normal yeah speak
normally speak like even when you're
saying what the judge said I'm like what
does that even mean yeah I don't quite
understand it all I still haven't been
given any paperwork to say what's
happened
yeah and like a balance of probabilities
like what the does that mean it's
like did it did he do it or did he not
do it yeah is there evidence or is there
not of it's like they bring in all these
words that mean nothing and just confuse
everybody and then say the man's the
like that's what I see the more
interviews I do it's just it's
ridiculous
it's not goodly it really isn't
um feminism has been so destructive for
women yeah I think over the years which
is a big part of a problem uh that uh
society's seen at the moment uh
behaviorally I don't think
um a feminism I think there was a point
in feminism where it kind of changed
from uh back back when it started when
the genuinely wanted rights and this
that the other you know there was a
certain section of women who did want
those Fades
um I think probably the majority didn't
because of what came with the rights but
yeah awesome that wanted the rights and
they were genuinely fighting for
fairness and equality I don't think I
don't think they ever were do you not
think so no I think I think it's always
freedom without the responsibility yeah
I think even I don't even think women
should vote too emotional yeah well no
that's why the laws that's what I've
been like from the research I've been
doing that's why the laws are so bad
because the politicians have to cater to
the women yeah they don't get re because
I'm guessing maybe judge does he get
elected is that how it works here uh I
don't know how it works for maybe that's
my my guess is maybe because
it's like if the women are the biggest
like voting block but it it used to be
that you would get drafted into war if
you voted yeah so that's why they didn't
want to vote but no but now they have
the freedom which I mean you could say
okay we haven't had the draft or
whatever but if goes south do you
know who's gonna suffer the consequence
of the men are still the ones fighting
like I'm so tired of them anyway oh the
women can join the military oh but
they're not
nobody's going to no little nobody's
fighting on the front like no woman is
gonna do that
like look at it um
country that's in war and all the like
women were just like I'm out of here in
Eastern Europe or whatever oh no you
know what I'm talking about yes I was
like just executing just extra Russia
Ukraine yeah you think the women are
sitting there oh I need to fight no
they're out like on first train please
yeah and it's even you said your job was
like building I forgot building it's a
construction industry yeah and so it's
like we don't do we don't build Society
at all none of our jobs do it yeah do
you see women fighting to be
construction workers
are we dominating in construction a
little problem no no no and so it's like
why do we get the same freedoms then
that the men when they do everything
yeah
I don't think today there is any
equality between men and women and I
think men have the
end of the stick on that one yeah
unfortunately you know there's um
there's double standard throughout life
and you know men do get the the good end
of it somehow you know like when men go
out and date several women it's not
really an issue but when a woman goes
out and six or seven men she's a slug or
yeah taught or whatever so it's a double
standard and win on that one but I think
generally uh
men are a lot more suppressed these days
than what women are I think women can
date women date several men so much more
often than men dates several you're
telling me the average guy is going to
have an easy time getting five women to
date or four it's not the same it's not
the same game you see God it would be so
so like but
but it goes back to like I I'm just so
tired of this is why I'm doing this
because I'm so tired of them saying that
oh it's just in cells it's like you're a
successful guy you know you you did well
you good job and yet they're just gonna
say oh it's just the incels that are
whining about this and it isn't it
really isn't it's very dangerous as well
the more things like that are just
pushed aside and just dismissed as being
uh small things like out in the small
minority and blaming it on that it's
going to blanket and it's going to yeah
seriously damage society as a whole uh
if things aren't nipped in the bud
someone needs to do something and
Society needs to start sorting itself
out especially when it comes to the
women of the world because no offense
put yourself running around but yeah I
know yeah you really are but even and
then they'll say like it's like men are
there's like oh it's just angry men that
are walking away from women when it's
like I listen to you guys as stories and
I'm like I will never talk to a woman
again
I'd be recording this whole thing too
I'd record every interaction I ever had
with chicks because it's like we have
such power that we could say damn near
anything yeah it's crazy and it's not
angry men it's not it's it's like you
don't even seem like you seem sad you
don't even seem angry about this whole
situation not angry at all I
I don't think
many people have ever seen me angry
about something including the ex-wife
you know it's not something that happens
um I could be frustrated in life and I
can be depressed down in life
but I'm not genuinely an angry man
things don't really push my buttons do
you know what I mean I get on in life
quite easily without you know stressing
out all the time and you know my hair
fell out I didn't pull it out kind of
thing you know but
I don't know
apparently I'm an angry man anyway I
kind of control my anger wheeler
what is there anything people can do to
like support you or help
um
it's very difficult because I think it's
at a point where
um if some assistance did come if
something did happen the amount that
would be uncovered would be too much so
I don't think there's any way for me to
go I don't think anybody wants to
to turn this Stone so to speak because
well you can it legally just abduct
people's kids you kind of do that yeah
you can't just say I don't like this
fella I'm going to go home write a
report and say I saw him beating this
kid on the street yeah and have the kid
taken away just because I don't like
them yeah you can't do these things
that's that's heinous it it's disgusting
yeah that someone some lady in an office
somewhere can be bored and just say eh
he's putting his garbage cans on my path
I'm gonna have his kids taken away from
him I'm going to come up with all these
stories about how he's aggressive and
threatening and yeah abusive and I'm
going to give it to the judge and the
judge will say oh well it must be right
because you've written to take his kids
right I don't believe
that that is legal to do I cannot see
that
being accepted yeah and
if any progress in my case was made and
people started opening it up and they
started looking and going
you can't just make these things up and
pinch people's kids that's a serious
offense that you've just committed there
and then the people that have covered
for her and the people that have covered
for that and this I think there's so
many people involved that no one's going
to turn around stop putting the local
authorities under the microscope and
saying right Mr Dawson you're the one
that's blowing this this thing up let's
start having people's jobs I don't think
legally it'll go anywhere so they're all
protecting each other because they're
all involved they're all involved
um the police
uh came out of my house
um and searched my house they said they
were there for a welfare check but they
weren't uh the search of my house and I
didn't know why I found out later when
they released a report uh to the local
Authority saying we attended Mr Dawson's
house he was belligerent and he wouldn't
let us see the Gabriella Gabriella was
scared and nervous we attended there
originally for a search for drugs and
this that and I'm thinking
when did this happen I don't know when
this happens I've got a video doorbell
and we'll put the phones on record and
record the audio and again it's come on
in would you like something to drink do
you know why we're here you said it was
a welfare check I was very polite and
they said uh it's Gabriella here I said
yep I'll give her now Gabriella and I
shouted her down and left the room let
them speak to her and then the next
thing I know apparently that's not what
happened I was belligerent I wouldn't
let them see Gabriella Gabriella was
scared when they did get to see him and
this and I'm thinking why did why why
make that whole story up I don't get it
and I had maybe it's a dozen recordings
which are supplied to the court which
the judge said that says more about me
than it does then
for making the recordings in the first
place what he said it says more about me
as a person recording someone than it
does them making up stories to take my
child wow yeah so he wanted nothing to
do with them we accepted free
and it was the initial response from the
local Authority when they came round and
said by the way Rosemary's gone into
foster care kind of thing
um who said that I was aggressive and I
threatened her and I was abusive towards
that and I was talking about my kids
genitalia
I don't know why they put that in I
think they're trying to get this
pedophile kind of vibe going on which I
said I was talking about my kids
genitalia which was massively concerning
and recording was submitted there was no
genitalia spoken about I don't talk
about kids genitalia and did they
rescind that no no they still put it
anyway they'll put it in yep and said
that's what happened they said the
recordings were cherry-picked and I said
it's the first thing
uh times I'd met someone they're not
terribly picked I give you all
recordings that's not Cherry Picked
that's all of them wow these were the
first three in succession the initial
encounter when my daughter first went
into care when she said I was talking
about genitalia that was all lies and
the tape recording proved it then it was
Cesar Nicholson came out said I was
threatening I was aggressive and I was
abusive and this uh the second tip so
that was all lies and that's the only
time I spoke to her the police came
around and said I was
I showed them to be lying
and the judge said people lie
why people lie he said we vote in the
order some kind of law so such and so I
don't know what Lord is but some law
that says it's acceptable a lie on the
roof
knowledge there's a law that says it's
acceptable to Lions acceptable the lion
wow and he acknowledged that every
single person that came up live he
acknowledged that all statements were
changed they came up and said it's still
the truth under oath yep it's still the
truth blah blah and then give a totally
different version of events
so he acknowledged that everybody lied
but when it came to me giving evidence
he says have you not got any notes Mr
Dawson that says no he says have you
been have you been given access to the
court bundle so you know I said no
he said why not I said I don't need
to look what's been said and done I know
what's been said and done
there's only one truth in the world and
I don't need to revise that I said ask
me any questions you want and what I'll
tell you now will be the same as I told
you a year ago it's not going to change
because the truth doesn't change only
people's version of events change
I said I'm here now with no preparation
of what's previously been done and said
and I don't mind because I'm going to
tell you the truth again the truth
doesn't mind
very nice questions but the lies do they
don't want to be questioned they wanted
to shut you up and get the hell out of
there so that they can just let the LIE
linger which is why the local Authority
won't answer any questions when my
Barrister was putting it to them
couldn't answer the question they just
said I don't know ask somebody else
because they can't remember what lies
they're told in the first place
and I answered every question and he
acknowledged
that I was telling the truth he
acknowledged and said I don't need to
write in this law that says about lying
I'm quite happy you've told the truth
today
right so let's go home then but even
still yep take the kid away
wow you've just acknowledged I'm the
only one what's told the truth do you
know any other man this has happened to
no I don't know no okay
I'm just wondering if this judge has
like a pattern of that yeah yeah well
like I said it was too blatant you
didn't try and hide anything yeah if
regardless of it you blatantly said yeah
they lied I know they've changed the
statements and yes you've told the truth
but take the getaway
ah that's what I said wow
I said that's amazing that you've made
that decision that's that's crazy how
you've made that I've proved everyone
and what pisses me off is it's like
these are young girls young girls
yeah and you're putting them with
strangers where you don't know who's
watching that like it's like just
especially as a young girl like that
that puts them in such a dangerous
situation yeah and especially if they
know that you're not lying they know
you're telling the truth like I don't
know why on Earth they would do that
but it's like for what money I wouldn't
know what it's called I have no idea
what kind of motive it would take to be
doing things like this yeah it's you
were mentioning something before about
[Music]
um
people being in certain occupations and
this is something I've been trying to
explain to my eldest and certain fields
people end up because they're passionate
about it you know like I wouldn't be a
child minder because I'm not passionate
about other people's children and
raising them in the giggles and you know
I know it might sound a bit cold but
yeah I'm not into
looking after other people's kids with
the cute smiles and yeah giggles and
Bubbles and stuff that's not me but some
young women young girls are into that I
love children so that's the field I'm
going into and I said it's the same with
child services it's not just something
they I need a job what job I'll be your
child services yeah it's not like that
you get into it for a reason that you're
passionate about children that you care
for children and I'm saying the way
they're behaving They Don't Care About
Children Well it's almost so what's the
reason they went into that field for
well it's almost
I mean I think they indoctrinate them in
the schools and just basically get like
put propaganda in the schools partially
and it's also like
women that haven't had kids so they just
want to go raise other people's and tell
other people what to do with their kids
I find this in teachers too yeah it's
just these like feminists that instead
of having kids of their own just want to
raise yours badly usually
it's funny you should mention
indoctrination yeah because
um it's a word they use to describe me
and say that I've indoctrinated the
children or my youngest child
specifically
and because obviously she's denied
everything saying what you're talking
about not abusive he's not this he's not
that no you know and they're saying
again she says he's not abusive and they
say you've been indoctrinated
indoctrinated the thing to these people
and what they've said I've got the
paperwork the vote this down yeah right
this is genuine
the one to take her away keep her out of
school keep away from family and friends
take all mobile devices off all that I
have no contact with the outside world
they're going to sit at down and they're
not going to let it go until she
understands she's been abused
I now said that is the exact definition
of indoctrination you're going to
indoctrinate her into thinking she's
been abused her whole life and you're
not going to let her go until she
accepts it wow again that's what I said
I just went wow that's amazing that
you've actually put that in black and
white to say that that's what you intend
to do with my daughter
and that's why they've said 18 minimum
18 before they're going to think about
letting it go and only if they say she's
emotionally capable so come in so if
they say she's not emotionally capable
goes into an adult institution no won't
let her go and wait okay
so if the government says we don't find
you emotionally capable which what the
those are these words it's like
what the does that mean emotionally
capable yeah that was the words they
used
they didn't say no what is an adult like
an insane asylum
uh kind of it would just be
like the care home for younger people
whether it would give you pills because
you're not thinking straight and they
wouldn't let you out because you would
danger to yourself and you can't look
after yourself and
I I really don't know what the plans are
for my kids I don't know what they're
trying to do wow because they won't go
into detail when you when you throw up
and you say okay like that I accept what
you're saying can you explain this to me
please why you've come to make these
findings they want nothing to do with it
that's it not speaking anymore don't
want to know anything else about this Mr
Dawson you're just not living in reality
you know what you should be asking is
um
how did you arrive at this decision I
said I've literally just used those same
words two minutes ago that that's it
finish don't answer any more questions
for them wow
do you have like the case File do they
give you that
no I'm not loaded wait what not loudest
I don't give you the how can they make a
ruling and aren't you legally able to
get it
no I can look at it in the presence of
other people but I'm not allowed to have
a copy
you can't take a picture you can't
not in the low pictures of anything
the judge thought it was being fair and
said um prior to one of the hearings he
said
um you're not getting a copy of the
bundle that's not happening but I will
let you go to the the council building
and look at it
wow and there I think Court was on the
Monday and Friday afternoon the local
Authority said do you want to come home
and have a look at the the file and I
said it's 1 100 pages long you're giving
me two hours to memorize that for court
on Monday
wasn't allowed a copy because everything
they were saying
um I was telling Gabriella she's saying
I had a meeting with my social worker
what did she say about us and I tell her
I'll say oh she said yes I'll do that
that didn't happen and I'm like baby
girl I'll forward the email this is what
the scene took place I wasn't there she
says well I've recorded it and that's
not what happened at all and I went this
is what they're saying baby girl and
they said well can't have them telling
her what we're seeing and I went why
they said can't you see how damaging it
is well why are you saying these things
if you know it's damaging why are you
saying these things about living
so and then they don't even let your
daughter talk about it either
nah she went in and saw the judge and
the judge said she came and saws a
really nice uh young girl said she
wanted to go back and live with her dad
and this that and that she doesn't want
to be where she is and they start but
she's not capable of making that
decision I'm going to make it and I'll
say she's not
wow
it's crazy because the government's just
coming in and basically deciding for you
what you can do with your kid yeah
wow this is Rich and they're gonna say
this is the Judgment you can't have the
file of how I came to this judgment yep
and if you talk about this
then we will arrest you essentially I
don't know what the plan to do I don't
care
I don't really care what what they say
you know it's my experience and I'll
talk about my experience and I will
share information with my daughters if
it's something related directly to them
yeah and they ask what's happened I'm
going to tell them
do you hope they see this
uh yeah yeah yeah I think they should
know like what went on I think it's
actually
because now it's like your 16 year old
or 15 or 15. almost 16 almost 16. yeah
she doesn't even know what happened so
she might have they might have been
telling her all these stories that
weren't even true
uh I would imagine there would be
um I wrote of a letter saying uh
no matter what happens
never feel guilty about anything never
blame yourself for anything like I told
you in Australia you can't ever do or
say anything wrong you're just a child
and you shouldn't be put into certain
positions it's not what people should be
doing so don't ever blame yourself and
don't ever feel bad about anything at
all and my number one always love you
always have and always will do and
you're always welcome in my life
it's abuse to say a lot they said and so
there was a did she get the letter I
don't know
I don't know anything all I know is what
they tell me but they said that letter
was abusive
this is a red
and at the same time even though
um the judge read the letter
and they said that
I'm blaming her for everything even
though I said you can't do us or
anything wrong don't let you know don't
let anyone blame you or nothing's your
fault you cannot be you know just be
yourself don't worry about all
is blaming here he's blaming everything
on here and that's not a good sign
because he's going to take it out on her
if she ever goes back to him
so it doesn't matter if I tell him I
love her
and that she cannot do anything wrong or
what I kind of do or say the right thing
no matter what I do or say
they've taken that away they've taken
all of that away from me so that I just
cannot speak on the subject at all I've
told the professional
who's highly regarded apparently
she asked me about Rosemary and I said
you know what it is I say is I thought
I'd felt pain because I've been through
a lot I've had bones broken and I'm
covered in scars off my ex-wife I've
been through a lot I've had tough jobs
over the time
um
so I understand what pain is but I told
this woman I said
I've never felt pain truly in my life
until the day I lose a child I said I
don't think any man understands just
what pain is until he loses a child I
said I feel so weak and Hollow and
useless inside and I don't know how to
to all of that and how to repair that I
said she's my daughter and I'll always
love her with all my heart and she'll
always have a place in my life
the professor went back to the judge and
said I find it massively concerned in
how he speaks about Rosemary
this man should be nowhere near a child
the rejection he shows towards her is
just
unimaginable she said
and I'm like
all I did was say I love her and she'll
always have a place in my life
what's concerning about that what you
should be concerned if a parent doesn't
say that about his child why do you
think that that's so concerning I
shouldn't have children
and how do you get rejections I would be
so bad I can't even imagine being this
course she said it's okay to get angry
you know Brian and I said it's not no
I'm not allowed to get angry
if you get yeah if you get angry it's
like they do the same thing yeah
but I didn't get angry and I said I
can't get angry but she still said I
have anger management problems oh wow
again that's the only word I've been but
it's like almost like they're baiting
you it's like they're trying to get you
as agitated as possible and as
frustrated as possible
and I haven't I haven't been yeah I
haven't lost it yeah I haven't raised my
voice I haven't been to rugby I haven't
been angry yeah no matter how much the
shout out is because I said uh child
abusers are deplorable yeah I said
anyone who harms a child is deplorable
and I went to the school one day because
um
the they put their hands on my daughter
which I'm not legally allowed to do we
kind of put their hands on her and
because they wanted to know uh what was
happening with court and she didn't want
to speak about it so the following
Chester from the school and cornered her
um at a certain part of the school and
said I'm not letting the album want to
know
what's been what's being said and this
that the other and the grabbed holder
one more than let her go and I went to
the school and she was in absolute tears
she came bursting through the doors when
they eventually let her out and she was
screaming and I thought my goodness I
took my phone out and I started
recording I says what have you done to
my child I went this is disgusting I
says you're scum I says Anyone who puts
a child through this is absolute scum
and when we're in court we shout
noticing who scum Mr Dawson who's
deplorable Mr Dawson tell me now tell me
now what I'm thinking
what are we on a schoolyard yeah he
wants to start saying he's mean he's
nice I don't get where you're going with
this one I've expressed My Views and
I've told you you know no I want names I
want names now tell me names who's the
who's this who's that and I'm thinking
wow I said I'm not going to be so
talking about people that aren't here
and telling you that the nasty and this
that the other I've made the statements
and and that's where we are with things
you know like
I don't know what you're going for with
this one you want us to start shouting
in Corners I don't know whether you know
but like you say I think it's all beaten
trying to get me down yeah which
obviously I never did which made them
even more angry one of the fellas nearly
fell down in court he was not old and
distressed and red face and oh Mr Dawson
and he was that head up that he was
leading on the desk and everything and
I'm like
it's only one angry man yeah and it
certainly isn't me I've sat and listened
to you talk about my children's
genitalia and I'm not getting angry
about it I says what man would let
someone sit and talk about their kids
genitalia and not be angry or and their
response was depends on the
circumstances
I thought it doesn't no it doesn't you
kind of pick them out on the street tell
him he's talking about kids genitalia
and then continue to talk to them about
his own child's genitalia for an hour or
so and not expect him to get angry he's
gonna get angry I says but I'm not angry
I'm just let down more than anything
else I'm just sad that this is happening
that you've gone to these extents
the the excuse they give for my
ex-wife's eldest also turning a back on
her mother
um
wasn't because of the way our mum was
they're saying that she's in a sexual
relationship with me and that's why she
left the house
so I had to let sit and listen to people
talking about me having a sexual
relationship with someone who I class
with my daughter
still didn't get angry
but I've got anger management problems
and an issue with authority and I'm set
in court the highest Authority being
bereed and listening to how I'm having
sex with my kids and I'm not angry
I don't get it because the actual
definition of anger management problems
is someone who cannot manage his anger
so if I can't manage my anger and I
don't like anyone in this quote will I
have an issue with your new anger me
anywhere and I'm listening to how I'm
having sex with my kids shouldn't I be
kicking off about now should now be
going yeah rampant in this courtroom but
it's like they're baiting you yeah wow
wow and it's
sick some of the things are actually
sick and twisted what I had to sit and
listen to when I call you it was
absolutely Harvard and I proved it all
to be lies and all he had to say about
it was some people lie
that's just the way things are
I'm so sorry I had to go through this
this is it's actually making me sick
that's so disgusting it just leaves you
lost what do you do in life when when
people can't literally just Eenie Meenie
mine anymore
yeah well we're in life right what's my
purpose now in life all I've known for
the past 20 years is a dad
I go to work to make money to come back
to treat my kids I have no kids
what's my purpose in life at the moment
all I can focus on is how can I get my
kids back how can I get this one out of
a care
facility this is you can't even you
can't even visit them or see him
um I think I'm entitled to one visit a
month
in the past four months I've had one
visit I've got a visit this month coming
in two weeks time okay
so I've seen that like I said I saw that
once on that one visit
and are they is it monitored I'm
guessing yeah yeah it's monitored yeah
and so you can't even like freely talk
to your kid because if you say the wrong
thing they'll just point it as evidence
as abuse too yeah yeah
wow the thing is when we did see her
um
there was nothing to pick up on because
we were just focused on seeing each
other and when we were giving kisses and
hugs at the end and I was telling how
much I love it and miss her
and the the people who were supervising
were clearing the tables and putting the
rubbish in the bins
but it came out in court that when I'm
giving a hug these people in a busy
restaurant it was um Pizza Hut or
something while they're clearing the
tables they heard me in an Embrace with
my child whisper in the way yeah
and don't worry baby girl it's all their
fault
and will make them pay or something like
that and I'm thinking even in a quiet
room
if I whisper directly into someone's
head you're not going to hear that
if you're over a whiz clearing tables
how is she listening to a whisper and
understanding every single word of that
defer it to be true
I said this is ridiculous now I said
like people are superhuman how is that
as evidence as you shouldn't see her
again yeah and the person saying he's
indoctrinated now he's telling the
things are on too
it's like it's like they're literally
just saying things you don't like which
in that case you didn't say anything
it's impossible for that to have been
heard even if I did say something yeah
you think these things are bad I'm sat
in court with a judge right talking on
face to face and then the courtroom
starts getting excited oh there's a
message come through from the school
oh what does it say
the Headmaster says Mr Dawson's on his
way down to the school now to get
Gabriella so we've got the police here
and I'm thinking I'm sat in front of you
you're running now in front of your very
eyes and even acknowledged at the time
you see her in front of me he's more
certainly not on his way to the school
and even if I was she was my child and
it was end of school time
so what's the problem the parent picking
up a child what's the police there for
but that's what the center to the to the
judge and the judge is like well I can
clearly see that he's in front of us but
he later made a statement saying that
that was true that I did do that
and there was another time when code
face to face where the school was saying
Mr Dawson's messaging information
and the judge is like well how because
this is stuff that we're only just
talking about now in court no one's
privy to this so how could he have told
her that
and the judges like Mr Dawson I said I'm
in front of you
I'm I'm here now in court he says you
better not be lying to me I said what
about being here with you
but I'm like what I've been here for the
past hour you wanna talking to you right
what do you mean I best be telling you
the truth right
where we're going with this but again
he's using that when he's making these
conclusions Mr Dawson passing evidence
Mr Dawson doing it and I'm like I was in
front of you right
how can you think that I bid those
things when I'm in front of you yeah
but he kind of just turned around and
say wow school you'll fabricating
evidence here that's wrong so what does
he do you must have done it then in
front of my very eyes he must have
vanished out the courtroom sent some
messages and came back in
where have you gone with this it's not
about evidence that's what I keep
telling people like this stuff is not
about evidence definitely not it's any
evidence you said I don't want it I
don't want recordings I don't want
documents I don't want anything like
that they're going to tell me what is
and what they say is true right
because they don't care about what's
true it's just pushing an agenda it's
pushing an agenda and it's doing what
they want to do and it's nothing about
truth and it's nothing about what's
right in life at all in any way shape or
form and it's so so sad and my daughter
as I was bringing them up and I was
telling Rosemary
um what you want to be in life when you
older as a solicitor
and she said why I said because you can
do a lot as a solicitor baby girl and
we've had some hard times in our life
and we've been really low and we haven't
had much money or anything I says
there's people in the world who can't
defend themselves baby girl and they
need an honorable decent person to look
after them and as a solicitor you'll be
able to do that and I supported
Gabriella and I said you should be a
police officer when you're older because
she's that kind the personalities of
that that way that they would suit those
roles I said you should be a police
officer and she said why I said because
then you can work with your sister and
when there's injustices in life the two
of you can help out people who can't
help themselves
another two paths that I kind of had
pegged out for them uh Rosemary still
really much wants to be a liar
Gabriella's not too fussed about being a
police because she's lost all faith in
the systems after going through Wallace
you know and it's a shame because
I truly believe that two decent people
in such in positions like that could
actually do good in life and they could
look after people
you know and
the same system I wanted them to be a
part of
is destroying them and dismantling them
and turning them into
well I don't know what but there's
certainly not educational based
because they think fun is more
important
than
education and a future
feelings are more important than facts
that's their stance on things
and it's like wow this this is untrue I
brought it up in court I says Rosemary's
education suffered and no it's not it is
I've been getting emails from the school
because they didn't take me off the
email list and it's telling us time and
time again she's flunking our subject
she's taking our exams she's failing
she's failing again and again and again
and again she keeps failing we need to
get extra tuition in Fuller and again
none of that happened and what what I
was looking after the children it's just
they went from mediocre to excellent to
now Phelan
and I'm saying can you not see the
pattern here yeah when the mother's
looking after and I'm working the
medioga when I have sole responsibility
look for yourself yeah the schoolwork
the rexella it's so clear and now the
feeling listen she's not failing she was
not failing I'm saying I've got the
emails from the school saying I want to
know them don't wanna their searches not
failing she's doing really well that's
what's happening and I'm like you
deliberately just letting everyone that
education just to try and make me look
like a bad guy yeah
it's like the need to be right the need
to be right it's like at all costs yeah
and it's costing me my children at the
moment it's costing my children their
freedom Gabriella kind of go anywhere to
kind of go and play with friends she
kind of go out and see family she kind
of do anything and if she does leave the
house she's either escorted or followed
and she's allowed to go to the shops and
back and that's about it she's got no
freedom in life
she used to go out she was a very
outgoing person she was an extra bit
she'll be out with her friends all the
time she'd be out
doing what kids do climbing trees she
was a bit of a tomboy which I got asked
the question do you know she's a girl
I'm pretty sure she's a girl you know
she's not a boy how do you know oh I'm
not going down that path love let's just
talk about heaven yeah sober but that's
the kind of path I wanted to start going
down with her because she was very
boyish she must be a boy yeah and the
girls are so impressionable too because
I was a tomboy too and I'm thankful
nobody put that idea in my hands yeah
because a girl especially girls we just
believe anything yeah
I think it's the way your friends or
wake it up yeah you I think is a lot
more emotional with your way of thinking
yeah you know I don't think it's a
something that you can help or anything
like that it's just the way you've been
provided the different domains well it's
it's because we with um babies we have
to like pick up on their emotions more I
think there's something to it where it's
like meant don't have that as much
because they were out like Hunter castle
Yeah it all stems back to all that in
your instincts and your basic needs in
life
which is why you guys can hear
high-pitched sounds better than we can
yeah you know yeah like if you're in the
house alone and a burglar comes in if
he's low in people quite you'll not hear
them but as soon as there's a
high-pitched noise yeah because you're
triggered and why did you hear the young
you wake up to that yeah and it's just
another example of how men and women are
entirely different when it comes to not
only just your physical appearance but
just the way people just like put
themselves in life and the the careers
they choose the paths the walk down it's
all set out by a biology you know I
don't buy into any of this
you know Tom's now Tina and Tina's yeah
Tom carry on yeah but it's like you
can't even protect your kids from it
because it's like in the school they're
telling them to have sex yeah in the
school they're pushing a lot of the
pronoun stuff yeah and if you don't fall
in line with the school they take your
kids away yep it's
it's not a good will to be living in
when things happen that easy yeah
well I really appreciate you coming in
today I know this stuff is like really
tough to talk about so
um are you you're able to send me the
recordings I am yes we can edit we can
edit them in yeah
um when we tell the story um is there
anything else you want to add about
about anything that happened
um
not really I've kind of touched on just
about everything that I found to be a
bit outstanding yeah
um but
it's difficult to talk about it but it's
something that needs to be spoken about
because the more this is ignored and the
more people don't talk about this and
push it under the carpet the worse it's
going to get yeah and kids matter it's
like fathers matter yeah and it's
actually disgusting that the government
has this much power that they can just
take your kid away yeah it is very
disgusting very disgusting indeed and
like I say the more they get away the
more they're gonna do it's human nature
yeah like you were saying before the
examples are given about steel and if
someone keeps stealing then yeah it's
done why stop yeah getting stuff it's
the same thing if people I guess can
just start taking kids when they want to
where does that end right you know what
is their end what do they want what are
the pushing for you know because what
what I find in life and what I've what I
kind of perceive anyway is that people
do a lot of little things to get one big
thing in the end
it's like
you know a group of a group of fans
hanging around and one girl says to
another girl like oh he's all right they
need like would you hook up with him
kind of thing the the putting thoughts
in this girl's head to say how nice this
guy is so they can get them together
it's like with with
um
like say for instance
something as basic as making you
breakfast you start putting cornflakes
in a bowl and then you put some milk in
a bowl and then you have a ready meal so
you're doing little things to make a big
thing and it makes you think that the
the local Authority is doing things like
this and treating Children and Families
like this what are the air wind for in
the end what's the main outcome that
they want to get from their actions
today where do they see themselves in 10
years time in 20 years time if this is
what's going on now if this is the
little stuff if this is the stuff that
they're just pushing through what's
going on behind the scenes and just what
is the extent of these things and I
think that's a lot scarier because like
I say I know for the fact that at least
one of their team members was a
pedophile and he was doing things with
children he shouldn't have been doing
right so what is the end game for these
people what is it right they need to be
protected from and what is it that they
put so much on the line to protect
because I wouldn't risk my job
just to get one over on someone I
wouldn't do that that's stupidity you'd
have especially in today's climate you
know what's the odds I'm going to walk
into another high paying job
why would they put their jobs on the
line
in order just to do what they've done
throughout this case
it's too blatant for it
to be something that it's almost like
it's an Institutional yeah that's what I
was saying it's almost like they get
money for doing this in some way there's
something there in the long run for them
and yeah it's a scary thought is there a
way if anyone wants to like you never
know who's watching because people that
can help you like do you have an email
or something
uh I do have a new Miracle yeah if you
if you want to put it um I've just had
lawyers or stuff like people that like
maybe help your case at all or find a
way to appeal it yeah if there was
anybody who was watching this yeah it
was in a position they got who decided
to want it off their health yeah it's
more than welcome because I'm not in a
position to help myself and I don't know
anybody who is in a position to help
like um like Twitter how would you want
them to reach out Twitter Instagram if
you email you could put whatever
[Music]
um
it's not something you know I didn't
come on here and look in the kitchen I
just came on yet to try and share an
experience yeah in order for for people
to understand what happens okay well you
can um you can tell me like later the
editor will just edit it in because a
lot of times we do have guys that like
try to help so yeah yeah you never know
well I don't mind Sharon okay I've got
an email address uh which is uh BNA
Dawson which is my name zero eight seven
six can you spell it out just so yes I
I've done this before yeah
[Music]
b-n-a-d-a-w-s-o-n-0876 gmail.com and
that's my email address I'm also I have
a Twitter account and Facebooks and
things like that just under my name
Brian Dawson you know so
if there was someone thought you know
genuinely if there was someone that
thought they could help or had
information that could help that would
be absolutely you know
something that I wasn't expecting like I
said I just think people need to be
aware that these things happen and it's
not like you say to in cells or yeah
Geeks and nerds it happens to Everyday
men I'm a I'm a hard worker I'm very
family orientated and I put my woman up
on a pedestal and this happened to me
after was it 15 years of being together
yeah and you did the right thing you
watched you took in her kids
which is a huge ask of a guy that's huge
and you were willing to do that
I hear that all the time that you know
it's a big ask to be taken on someone's
there someone's children and especially
when there's four of them but it wasn't
something that's uh specifically
um well well I stayed with her for the
children
so there weren't a burden because they
were tagging with her she kind of tagged
with the children because I met her on
an Internet site it was only meant to
just be a little bit fun do you know
what I mean yeah and but when you look
at the environment when children are in
and you look at the the Social Circle
that the mother's moving in anything
whoa
these kids are are going in a dodgy old
yeah yeah no that that's not good that
and I kind of stuck around to try and
give them a bit of guidance yeah and try
and shove them away from what they were
doing and show them something better you
know they went from a a rented house in
Berwick where they were relocating
pedophiles uh to a nice country
a bit of land with a nice country house
on it and you know we had our own
business and I'm saying look see what
life can be like this is for you I don't
want any of this it's built it's there
it's formed this is for you guys I'm
just showing you what life can be like
instead of scrimping and scraping the
barrel and you know one of one of my
wife's best friends at the time her
daughter was only like
well 12 13 and my mom's laughing and
bragging about how our uh 24 25 year old
boyfriends always sleep around the night
with her and this that the other and I
thought
these kids the eldest is nine
and if this is the lifestyle that
they're getting brought up into that's
not really a good one do you know what I
mean so I only really stuck about for
the kids in the first place to begin
with yeah but my point is like you were
doing the right thing like that's what
we encourage men to do to step up be
better and it's like and and like do you
know do the right thing when you had
kids you stayed around for the marriage
and everything but it's like you guys
are punished for doing the right thing a
lot of the time yeah
and it's very disheartening yeah you
know men
are big and strong generally but when
we're still vulnerable we're not you
know we're not Immortal and we're not
Untouchable we're not made of stone
regardless of how tough and we'll get
the exterior is we could always be hurt
you know we could always be brought down
and I just think it's a shame that
people look for that instead of building
up because
um what what I believe anyway I mean
this could be misogynistic sexist
whatever but I strongly believe that if
you have a strong woman in a household
who's lifting up a strong man you have a
strong household yeah and you know your
children are going to be raised in the
correct environment with the right
guidance and you're going to have strong
children who are going to be independent
and have a good life I think if you've
got a strong man
and a woman who's bringing them down all
the time you're not going to have a
strong unit the unit's divided first of
all but your man's only going to get
weaker he's not going to get any
stronger why would you want the captain
of your ship so to speak or the head of
your house or why would you want that
week why wouldn't you want it strong so
you can look after you in defend and
provide for you well I just I don't
think they actually want families I
think they'll govern they want the
government to be the parents yeah that's
that's what I think whether it's through
the school or daycare like I think I
don't think they want strong families
yeah
um
but I really guys if you know anyone
that could help his case
um you know I've had some guys get legal
advice so maybe there's something they
can do who knows yeah
um thank you so much for coming in
um I know you you came so far so it's
nice
um okay guys
um make sure you go you want to give
them your Twitter too they can follow
you I don't know what my Twitter name is
okay okay I thought it would just be my
name oh okay I don't know uh make sure
you like the video on your way out and
subscribe to the channel um and let me
know in the comments if there is you
know anything that he can do to fight
this sort of thing it could be helpful
um
yeah make sure you guys subscribe to the
channel I will talk to you next time